[Music]
I lead the CHARM lab. It's the Care Health And
Reasoning Machines Lab. And we develop
machine learning tools to better utilize
electronic health records data for patient
characterization and for risk assessment.
Part of my work focuses on longitudinal data
that comes from electronic health records so
that we can do forecasting, so that we
can know a patient's risk for particular
sequelae of disease forward in time, or
we can at least estimate it or predict it.
Another part of my work focuses on Equitable
Risk Assessments so that the models that we
develop have performance characteristics
across different subgroups that may be
of interest. We don't want the models to
underperform in any particular subgroup.
A third line of work is to better
understand electronic health records
data because electronic health records
data are a little bit different than
other types of clinical data in
that they're passively collected.
They're collected by indication as
in the provider has to seek out that
information for it to be entered into
the electronic health record. Whether
or not something is there is
makes the data incomplete.
Not every patient is going to
have every measurement collected.
And so, we try to understand how do we
build models that capture this type of
data irregularity and be able to use it for
prediction and for characterization purposes.
I think that better healthcare
going forward is data-based policy,
data-based healthcare. And that's why we need to
develop tools and methods that help utilize that
data the best we can so that we can make
the most informed decisions for patients.
[Music]
[Music fades to silence]